third time in probably less than 30 days
that gyms [ __ ] has interrupted the
show okay going to detail yeah now see
at least this time he had the decency to
leave during the commercial break and
he's just late coming back but twice
before this it's been mid show where
he's like I I gotta go I'm gonna I'm
gonna [ __ ] my pants those any shits and
just now during the break it was uh it
was okay I just gotta piss real quick
before I come back to do the commercials
and we go okay and he goes but I feel
the ship rule no good person has ever
referred to a [ __ ] as brewing yes yeah
that sounds like like like an evil side
of me yeah like old sailors we're
piecing the show back together slowly
but surely what happened Jim is [ __ ]
yeah as it's brewing yes she is the
default head of the show now Sam I mean
yeah there's two of us so I'm the one
that's left yes all right yes the [ __ ]
is brutal a was brewing I'm assuming
it's in the process of being brewed yeah
now it's percolating browning browning
right no handshake what I miss how just
talking to Gilbert about the the concept
of [ __ ] brewing oh yeah she was brewing
oh yeah yeah yeah bubbling inside it was
it's my second caffeine caffeinated
beverage now now was it did the [ __ ]
come out in the solid shape for her well
honestly it looked like it looked like I
was bleeding because I had I had I had
beat a beet drink yesterday right you
shat and it was the inside of the toilet
was solid
not big but read we've all lived that
life it's good seeing you and four I see
you're wearing your Christmas blouse
always brings the feel of like an
Albuquerque lesbian he's gonna talk to
us about water conservation yeah I guess
so
it's your does your adult look because
what in your documentary we see that
many looks of you oh yeah I'm the 80s
did you see Jim I did yes oh my god yeah
yeah I had that was like Michael Jackson
right hairstyle lifestyle I don't try to
hide that what was the name of that
Macaulay Culkin note the the letter
yeah wet weather what was when you alone
sure happy yeah just just short
overweight and people still call him
Webster so what's wrong with both him
and Gary Coleman I heard that biggest
complaint was you know they were like
they were getting older right and so
they'd be like you know in their mid
forties or whatever hell they were and
you know when it was time you know guys
on the set right you know you see
someone that's wrong you assume it's a
little kid and they would pick and it's
like you know and you're a grown man and
you have people picking you off Monday
it's great that's gotta be so great I
would love call men just to pick me up
random kids you're 20 and people are
just coming up in like pinching you I
yeah but at least he died with dignity
he fell down the steps thank his little
head one guy on my podcast
Gilbert Godfried amazing colossal pot it
is a very good party and he was went
into detail of what a prick I heard a
villager Ricardo Montalban yeah he was a
bitter yes I mean you know you'd you'd
have to imagine successful you would
think that some of the success and the
fact that he could get women after he
was successful would like ya outweigh
the fact that it was fisted out tiny he
that was the problem he he was like he
was jealous of Tom Selleck and he said
he should be making Tom Selleck's money
and as much pussiest I'm selling right
running around in the 80s just I had
that little tattoo is jealous of Tom's
anyway he had a good head of hair that
[ __ ] guy see God takes God gives I
heard to give him more reason to be I
heard like his insides were a normal
person's the size of a normal person's
insight
no yeah it was packed in that explains
the voice yeah
[Laughter]
just sit there he's kidding you know
when he's a kid everything's fine and
the older he gets the boy and they said
his hands could not break probably [ __ ]
yeah he went dry he would go up to women
because he couldn't he needed help with
his fly to women on the set and these
women of course would complain too that
this isn't in my child Harvey Weinstein
and heard a valid survey went after they
had their me one and a half
[Laughter]
does that mean to put his dick back in
his pants
little wheelie on the helmet have a
couple of drops he was kind of cute
though when you look at him like a big
kid oh look at the little guy what hair
on him this bond movie I don't know oh
that's right yeah what was his name in
that one I'm wearing a little suit and
and you know this he he was a gun nut
another looking girl and she's probably
going oh god get this disgusting [ __ ]
away he had good now she probably was
admiring his hair
[ __ ] head looking guys really his
hair like herb Harlech he was singing a
song on some seventies variety not like
oh my god not in character yeah yeah
well he was always in character because
he always had that voice and he was
always a foot oh my god what is or does
anybody have a pistol oh he's the
singing he's a talk singer is that a
song or a riddle
what is he right look I bet you they
tape his little hands to that microphone
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so he could have trouble getting was
this before he was tattoo is that the
before right this way after when he was
already famous had to be after tattoo
it's not like they heard the voice 1981
Epic Records single passion
is the red shirt what's he doing that
little red shirt Ricardo montalbán
discusses working with Herve Villechaize
here they are together this is great
look at me and my shadow sing me in my
shadow Thank You Marvin he's got a shirt
[Laughter]
they got the line of the Impressionists
and they do but I don't think you ever
say that in the show now here's what
they do ladies coming that's not right
is it
top of the tower it was a chair story
does he sing I don't need him talk I
don't want to hear his [ __ ] logicians
too short but he's long-winded it's his
single clear this is much better I love
that this was his single I love it too
like you put it out in your recording
artist forever had to run off of invent
wheel of fortune excuse me hold the fort
little man
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was a simpler time then you don't
want to be recognized 70s like the
average guy adopting the hippie look
yeah but what was his name in the James
Bond movies because he he really was
like he made that movie oh yeah I forget
which one that was there was a picture
of it earlier he's like a wearing a
little tuxedo when they have Peter
Dinklage he must hate that guy
Peter was eight that guy Peter doesn't
like any of that stuff Peter Dinklage is
making a movie where he plays Irv a
villages Wow
yeah well I think you look at her veil
ago like a nephew Tom or something just
trying to get some of that Tom Selleck
[ __ ] yeah is he playing yeah what's his
name in the in the movie it's like a
knick-knacker on a shelf a little guy
James Bond in there was that let's see
it was 1974 yeah is that Roger Moore
said you're more mad for more indeed he
was cheap I love that they called him
Nicky Herve Villechaize is just an
accessory yeah was just too degrading
Oh Christopher is Christopher Lee in
that one yeah sure something they called
that's remember name like I love
Christopher Lee you ever see our serial
Martin mall and Sally Hellerman where he
plays the [ __ ] gay biker we're tough
dudes Holroyd it was such a good movie
no no I never seen that it's a comedy
from like 1980 mmm he was great in Lord
of the Rings
I heard the couch my Star Wars talking
Christopher Lee he wore a toupee and I
heard he was so egotistical when he
would be in full makeup like the mummy
frankenstein looked like really the
heaven like the mummy and frankenstein
and all this like full body makeup they
would have him they'd apply a light on
top of the toupee he wouldn't even take
the to pay off little more when he was
good for him what case it fell off he
did wanna be made a fool out of right
he's the best Dracula is it really by
far yeah but is America ready for a ball
Dracula male pattern balding Dracula
immortal and bald I'm a Lugosi fan no
Christopher leaders better Lugosi was
good yeah Gilbert knows everything about
horror like all that old-school horror
stuff
yeah it's pathetic studios they shot
with Christopher Lee a hammer
Wow need my [ __ ] yeah so Gilby you in
like today's horror movies or anything
like that
watch him okay like get out did you see
that no you didn't see it was that that
sounds like a haunted house one no
that's the yeah go ahead Sam what was it
revealing so what it's a black guy
visits his white girlfriend's family and
they're very wait wait wait with samuel
l.jackson no no right where he's a crazy
cop no that was a few years ago oh no no
that was unlawful entry with Ray Liotta
Romero last of the Mohegans yummers what
the [ __ ] happens to these actress no I'm
a big Tuesday Weld guy I'm still waiting
for her oh god I heard I think David
David Steinberg oh I used to [ __ ]
Tuesdays with the chameleon yeah for him
on Wednesdays Wow David's time are you
think yes I was The Tonight Show all oh
yes he's a funny dude man
yeah there's new director now he
directed a lot of a lot yeah my crazy
he directs all these TV shows he was a
little alt before the time I think it
was a storytelling and whatnot
name-dropping yeah
Groucho yeah he's very good mmm
but I didn't know he [ __ ] Tuesday well
that's nice to know so Gilbert when you
take your kids because your kids are
young like these movies you don't take
them said the old horror movies right
now now I try to get them to watch you
know there's no way they would look at
that yeah oh my god it's so weird now
yeah well so what do they like like
who's what's their horror now ah please
yeah what have they been taught in that
liberal school I did teach them that you
know like a you know I'll ask my son
like who played the Wolfman right a Lon
Chaney jr. Wow and who played
frankenstein Boris Karloff Jackie
crazy how do you say his name then what
Lugosi though same first name Bayla obey
locate others Bela
no no because uh it and it so even in
the Wolfman he plays a character named
Bale ah yeah and yeah pila go see crazy
what did lon chaney die of [ __ ]
everything really lana kane it was the
big man then uh yeah
Lon Chaney jr. yeah he was I mean he
died of throat cancer right but he had
you know I mean he was a drinker and a
smoker so he had a million other
diseases so he was a character he's the
guy who wasn't he raised by two mute
parents right now that's lon chaney
senior oh I'm sorry
Lon Chaney jr. he was Frankenstein yeah
he played he was the only one to play
old for universal monsters thank you Wow
you love the mummy and wolf Wow Wow I
played Dracula I he uh he played Dracula
yeah what in son of Dracula oh that one
that one he just did that one for the
money though right Lenny from my cement
or no one like this I'm gonna turn into
a bat kill me with the snakes
[Laughter]
that's a dead-on impression of someone
we have no idea each other you do my
mom's friend if you don't mind me saying
so darn good Lenny I didn't like Gary
Sinise's interpretation right so you
start like you go to the theater with
your kids yeah I mean more what do you
take him to is it the same one that
DeNiro took [ __ ] what's her name -
his simple shepherd
what are they like oh well they like kid
stuff
how they yeah eight and ten okay yeah if
you saw the documentary and by the way
we want to know why Jim was cut out of
it all right
let's not dance around anymore I know
you had director's cut what happened
there the premiere and you know he was
sitting there and he was watching the
movie Tom Hall was sitting next to
what's-his-name from F Troop large
storage storage and he realized about a
half hour into the movie when some of
the commenters on your life we're going
would be important it back to for a
second or third time yet she realized
that Jim's first time was not coming
that is the worst thing about doing
movies yeah is you go to see it and you
go oh you know here's my shot at stardom
yeah and then you go okay they probably
moved it to later and the director
didn't tell I had a date oh my god
I still [ __ ] him in the mouth date is
going you're in the Larry Storch section
I went alone I went solo Gilbert have
you ever been cut out of a movie like
cuz you were to make movies oh I've been
yeah here's here's a list of some movies
have been cut at him that I wasn't good
enough for this thing double dragon of
course yeah I remember in the movie I
was cut out of on another you the
lifestyle my movie gene Wilder Richards
effects are yes which was scary yeah
yeah one was that that one was blind one
was deaf no no another you was was that
when Richard was walking real slow I
remember yeah Richard looked like he had
already died what would you play in that
okay it took a lot of it took place in a
nut house
in the nut nut houses in movies are cute
adorable nuts and so I got fired from it
first the director got fired that was
Peter Bogdanovich and then I I was fired
in some of the other casts they scraped
old previously shot footage and redid it
and oh and they got in a Kevin Pollak ah
that's one of the nuts and this is what
gets me I want to get every psychiatrist
and mental health expert in the world
cause this is in so many movies and TV
shows and go has there ever been a case
of a crazy person doing celebrity and
[Laughter]
it's like that's in so many movies where
you got a guy doing celebrity and
operations I love it yeah you gotta love
it never gets old I love it yeah well
why don't you just put him in Las Vegas
and let him make a fortune it's like I
don't see the how that's a crazy trade
how many things did you shoot uh are you
except out I don't know a couple of
weeks
did you shoot with uh with gol-dern
Pryor III wasn't with them directly
Pryor actually was really nice to me
really he knew who I was can you do his
voice and cuz Kevin can yeah yeah he
would come up to me go oh you know Casey
they're dreadful you are so funny
butcher fire was that he was great in
Dracula also sounds like he was in song
in the south yeah did you meet Jean at
all ah I met him but he seemed like
you're more serious and I think he
probably realized he was in a piece of
[ __ ] with another great film
Oh bullet I heard in one theater in LA
they were showing that one time a day
that's how it wasn't work that's nice
running in a bunch that's bad was it
long like your documentary or PBS is a
little shorter never seen he does with
the photos guys I hate to be sure to
bring them all right it's like they're
alive movies but you've done like at
least 10 right yeah but I oh I was also
cut out of blank man blank boys that
about that was hollow man Damon Wayans
character for me oh yeah
what was that night or Jim Carrey had a
Sven Chara and Damon Wayans had Blankman
and that was like the big like in living
color David we're supposed to be the guy
and when you put Harry
he plays black man I know but what did
overplay I was like some funny gangster
or something and you were heavy yeah
yeah but he was yeah and do your George
Raft listen here
they decided not to use it though let me
see what else why didn't cut you had a
black man you know ah God wasn't good
enough I did it but you don't seem to
let things bother you did it bother you
when you got cut out of these movies
where you hurt by you're afraid it's
when when when it's a movie that bed and
you're cut out of it it's a mixed thing
that's one way you're happy that you're
not involved but in another way you
think I was good enough alright I'll go
home yeah
no they it's it's after it's completed
close once it fired they didn't fire you
in the middle of it yeah oh I think what
Blankman the director said that my
Saints didn't fit in with the narrative
say that I mean you do si mafioso like
but once again once you go from like
your problem child which was huge and
then Aladdin which was like out of the
stratosphere yeah like what you got that
lady kind of doesn't matter anymore
right yeah you'd hope it doesn't but you
could still get cut out of [ __ ] what
else everything cut out well you you
were and look who's talking to ya was
your fault in that oh yeah how do you
treat you did it cuz you really a little
younger than did he did he did he take
notice of you do the st2 massage him all
the chef's made a burger oh never
unhappy days heard you were casted they
canceled the day didn't do the episode
the one where mrs. Cunningham is rape
play again
there's a one white gang member no she
look like a likable North Korean time I
open up the gate see now that's the
thing had I been born a couple of years
yes I could have been an Indian chief on
fqu really so like this seven late
Senator Lee 80s would be like your yeah
yeah ad so Wonder Years baby or uh you
know always don't want the little robot
chick small wonder yeah small wonder I
heard I know I heard what small wonder
that one duck one of the actors who
played her brother yeah I think they
were put in some tabloid was living
under a bridge Wow
yeah well yeah he was like no after no
that does not compute it's funny though
you think those residual checks was
small one would keep you gone I guess
not player I thought it was like so many
them got got screwed on the residual
checks Williams guy and he's talked
about that a lot how they just didn't
get the money
yeah most I heard it reference that um
even watch this name dead David Faustino
for an hour children children I heard he
didn't get residuals forever who got
them from The Honeymooners Joyce
Randolph is the one brother was a lawyer
yes and I yeah her brother was a lawyer
and she said I'm having my brother
negotiate the deal and they were like
laughing your brother and and one of his
demands was that she'll get paid every
time it's shown which they laughed at
too because they said hey you watch it
once yeah what's the reason I keep
showing it they didn't understand yeah
so they said yeah yeah okay she'll get
paid
so they put that in it and yeah cuz I
mean that's like there are these shows
that get showed like 24 hours a day I'd
love to know how much she made and did
it decrease over time cuz they never saw
cable TV coming yeah so maybe it just
stayed the same every time but it
couldn't been that much I'd love to know
how much money she made from that show
after the 50 years of budding shows it
is funny too when you get sometimes I'll
open my mailbox and and they'll be like
ah you know it looks like a thousand
residual checks in there and annum and
I'm thinking oh my god I'm gonna buy an
island in Hawaii with this and III
add them all up and it comes to like a
dollar to I know I go to the bank with
those tooling also once in a while give
like a lucky Louie one for six cents so
they don't enter into foreign
distribution in Indonesia you got to
write him down and put him in the bank
it's kind of humiliating I've got I have
one and a frame that I got for a penny
I like the paper it's written on is what
was it 40 never III oh I was in this
movie oh that I was cut out of but they
paid me anyway what happened that one
Teri Garr and Jeffrey Jones oh my god
John I'll trade with him yeah I was cut
up but they send me a residual check
from penny and I put it there with a a
fortune I got from a Chinese restaurant
that said your talents will be
recognized and suitably rewarded it's
these crazy chicks you'll get for a
penny I have a Richard Pryor I bought
one off eBay was Richard Pryor's
residual check was the Aaron Spelling
production of the Mod Squad do you think
is real yeah yeah she's a $5 Richard
Pryor check that was never cashed -
Richard Pryor from Aaron Spelling
productions like yeah I don't think that
and when I when I framed the
anyone then they sent me another
authorized letter saying we have it in
our files
that you did not cash the last check did
you receive it so they they sent me
another penny channel that's three
letters yeah all of a sudden you got
yourself exactly guess how many residual
checks this blouse costs let's see how
many one-man shows that they've had oh
oh
defending the cave man that was joy
that's a gold mine by the way that that
one the guy who created that that is
gold mine that's like all international
and is he still doing it no he's not
he's like franchised it out he dies no
he didn't die it wasn't dog something or
he did like one or two Letterman's and
then after that he went right into this
display that is the dream I mean not do
that you stay at home and collect chicks
you should come out and and just do your
characters you start as Bela Lugosi or
how you work your way down to Herve
Villechaize the funny thing is on those
one-man shows see when you do stand-up
it's like you gotta be funny every
second up there in a one-man show you
talk for an hour yes and then you'll say
oh and when I'm on the couch
I hold the remote control and everyone's
like oh and and it's like sounds like a
joke good enough yeah I love the one-man
shows when the pictures come up that's
my favorite part when you're talking
about multimedia schenectady and all of
a sudden
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well Brooks came who Dan it was Rob
something who did we find is fighting
the caveman Oh only only the truth is
funny was another one of those one man
she in the cave it's Bennie and the Jets
new have any in the cave man what is it
where would you do your one-man show if
you're defending the cave man Todd I
think that scares me where you live
[Laughter]
Becker okay yes he stopped doing it a
while ago and he franchised it out and
it's like all over the you know it's
world thing it's like a dream yeah to
have a franchise you swear franchising a
one-man show that's like a whole new
world
yeah it's like Cirque du Soleil or
something oh that's so good the jokes
they do is a thing of you just collect
your check sister kiss is working on
doing right just franchising the band
out let him do it so makeup what do you
uh did you ever see uh would you say
circle so as you're seeing those
Zumanity
know when you cut out a Blue Man Group
one time my agent sent me up to be out
good yeah I keep my phone on that makes
a glass see that would be a big joke in
a one-man show and of course I leave my
phone
yeah and then you answer it in your
wrist back and forth with the person let
me pH no I can't make today and it's
Dustin Hoffman and my finger smell I
think it was Harry Hamlin doing a
reality show no and one part of the
reality show it's like they're opening a
store or something and in on a talk show
and this was so [ __ ] false I mean
it's like he's there and in the middle
of the interview his cell phone and he
takes out his cell phone on the air like
you'd really do that and he go oh I
better take this and you know first he
acted a little okay can't believe I left
my phone on and he takes it I goes what
there was a fire in the store oh my god
the story talked about on my reality
show there was a big owned everything
and this was 1975 so the cell phone with
a cord it was one of those like get
Canon head or shape by the belt which
one of the fat pig detective have in his
car was that cannon when you did wife
swap was that all real like when you
were you did wife swap with the with the
late great yeah you kept annoying his
wife by doing an Allen cuz this song I
was on Thicke of the night old so and
boy but talk about also a blessing but
also like the biggest insult god I was
like and I got fired from that but he
used
he's he wrote and sang the theme song of
the night did you remember when everyone
was strenghthen cash in on the robust
ice-crazy
Olivia newton-john had a tremendous hit
with let's get physical
I forget what hers was what was the
Diana Ross or Oh besides I don't know
but whatever I improbable get me fired
[Laughter]
one where everyone's dancing around him
in spandex and he's good to me so now
you had it sexual whole time she's
getting pissed because he keeps doing it
and she was getting angry and angry or
saying no he doesn't sound that way and
then I found on the internet him singing
sweaty and and she looked at it with her
jaw hanging open Joseph oh my god Oh
[Music]
well the good oppression there's no
blurred lines that's for sure the lines
is strictly drawn is that collar going
up later in the song I think so no
undeniable toe-tapper